Albert to the skier okay yes any mana  mana for Sophia baka Polly  you check apologia is  Roger it's really special to see the  block Rhine a since we started here we  have seen only six Rhine on here they  from Maasai Mara Kenya the seed so they  used to cross the river and they come  this area here because now a day Masai  Mara - looks crowded they say that they  destroyed their habitats that's why  they're coming this side I will look at  the ears you can see them say they have  a notch just how to identify this before  theirs is estimated that there are two  thousand rhinos  but nowadays there are just a few  because of the poachers here  now there are endangered species